>> Greg: HERE WE GO.
YEAH.
HERE YOU ARE.
HAPPY TUESDAY.
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
OH, WOW.
SOMEBODY JUST DIED OVER THERE.
SO, OUR DUMBEST POLITICIANS ARE
GETTING DUMBER.
IT'S LIKE A SEMITRUCK PULL OF
DUMB PILLS, OVERTURNED AND GAVIN
NEWSOM LEAPED OUT OF HIS LIMO
AND ATE ALL OF THEM UP AND NOW
HE'S OD EAGLE ON DUMB.
-- ODING ON DUMB.
>> I WATCHED JESSE WATTERS WHAT
HE'S BEEN SAYING ABOUT PAUL
PELOSI IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS,
MOCKING HIM, CONSISTENTLY, DON'T
TELL ME IT'S NOT AIDING AND
ABETTING.
OF COURSE IT IS.
IT'S A CULTURE, A CLIMATE LIKE
THIS.
LOOK ON-LINE.
LOOK AT THE SEWAGE THAT'S
ON-LINE.
>> Greg: SURE, GAVIN, SURE.
HE LIVED IN A BUS, BUT HE
DEFINITELY HAD CABLE.
GAV TALKS LIKE THIS MANIAC SAID
HIS IMAGINARY DVR ON HIS
IMAGINARY TV ON FOX NEWS EVERY
NIGHT WHILE WEARING BRIAN
KILMEADE PAJAMAS, DRINKING HIS
OWN URINE OUT OF A FOX NATION
MUG IN HIS BEAUTIFUL,
E
DILAPIDATED BUS OF HOME.
GREAT.
THIS IS RICH.
FROM THE PARTY THAT CALLS
EVERYONE A NAZI OR A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
CONSERVATIVE BLACK POLITICIAN,
WHITE SUPREMACIST, LATINO
REPUBLICAN, WHITE SUPREMACIST,
JIMMY KIMMEL?
FUNNY?
SEE, NOTHING MAKES SENSE.
AND THE REST OF THE CROWD WHO
DENIES CRIME EXISTS, THEY AIN'T
MUCH BETTER.
TAKE IT AWAY, FART BLASTER
SUPREME.
>> THE VIOLENT POLITICAL
RHETORIC THAT'S ESPOUSED BY
REPUBLICAN LEADERS IS INSPIRING
VIOLENT POLITICAL ACTS BY
INDIVIDUALS LIKE THIS.
>> IT IS A UNIQUELY RIGHT WING
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
WE CANNOT BOTH SIDES THIS GIVEN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
>> THIS IS A SICKNESS, BUT IT'S
NOT DIVORCED FROM THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> THE RIGHT HAS BEEN PLAYING
THIS GAME FOR A LONG TIME.
>> PEOPLE IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHO HAVE BEEN FUELING SOME
OF THESE CONSPIRACIES --
>> THERE'S TOO MUCH VIOLENCE,
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
TOO MUCH HATRED.
>> ENOUGH IS ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> Greg: WELL DONE, KIDS.
YOU ALMOST GOT US TO FORGET IT'S
YOUR POLICIES, YOUR DEFUNDING,
YOUR AMBIVALENCE THAT ALLOWS
MAYHEM TO RULE.
BUT BACK TO GAVIN BLAMING JESSE,
IT'S SO GOOD.
IT'S A BATTLE OF THE
NARCISSISTS.
WHAT -- ONE IS A GOOD-LOOKING
TYRANT WHO SPENDS TOO MUCH TIME
ON HIS HAIR.
AND THE OTHER IS GAVIN NEWSOM.
HE NEVER WATCHES.
GAVIN'S RANT, THOUGH, IS WRONG
ON TWO LEVELS, WHICH IS ONE MORE
LEVEL THAN HIS ELEVATOR GOES TO,
IF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
ONE, ONLY I CAN BLAME JESSE FOR
STUFF.
WELL, MAYBE ME AND HIS WIFE AND
HI KIDS.
BUT IT'S MY WHEEL HOUSE, YOU
BLOW DRIED SHAPE SHIFTER, SO
STAY OUT OF IT.
AND SECOND, WHY NOT BLAME THE
GUILTY PARTY OF THE ACT INSTEAD
OF MAKING IT ABOUT WORDS.
LIKE MADONNA'S PLASTIC SURGERY,
IT'S NONSENSE ON IT'S FACE.
-- ON ITS FACE.
YOU KNOW, SON OF SAM KILLED
PEOPLE BECAUSE HE LISTENED TO
HIS DOG.
SO, LET'S BAN DOG OWNERSHIP
SINCE YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT THOSE
MUTTS MIGHT BE PLANNING.
SPEAKING OF, HERE'S MY LITTLE
GUY, HUH?
YEAH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Greg: HIS NAME IS GUS AND
HE'S ADORABLE AND HE TELLS ME TO
DO TERRIBLE THINGS LIKE BE NICE
TO STEVE DOOCY AND STEAL MONEY
FROM STEVE VAR KNEE.
JESSE REPORTED ON PAUL PELOSI,
WHO HAPPENED TO BE NEWSOM'S
RELATIVE, HE REPORTED ON
PELOSI'S DUI.
IS HE SUGGESTING THAT THE PRESS
SHOULDN'T COVER ANY LAW BREAKING
BY POWERFUL PEOPLE BECAUSE
PEOPLE MIGHT COME AFTER THEM.
HOW CONVENIENT FOR POWERFUL
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT KILLED KENNEDY?
THAT BAY OF PIGS COVERAGE.
THAT'S A CALL BACK.
SO, YES, PLEASE DON'T REPORT ON
MY STOCK TRADES, MY MASKLESS
PARTIES, OR RECKLESS DRIVING,
BECAUSE THAT MIGHT RADICALIZE
ONE OF 375 MILLION PEOPLE.
ARE THEY WORRIED ABOUT CRAZY
PEOPLE, OR, WELL, IF THEY WERE,
KEITH OLBERMANN WOULDN'T ROAM
FREE, THAT'S FOR SURE.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT SANE
PEOPLE REALIZING WHAT'S CRAZY.
BUT LET'S PRETEND THEY'RE RIGHT
FOR A MOMENT.
THAT'S THE SOLUTION THAT MIGHT
BRING.
DO WE POLICE LANGUAGE BASED ON
UNSTABLE REACTIONS TO SUCH
LANGUAGE.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
DO WE APPOINT A BOARD OF CRAZY
PEOPLE TO JUDGE WHAT UPSETS
THEM.
YOU CAN'T CONTROL THE LANGUAGE
OF MILLIONS TO PLACATE THE TINY
MINORITY OF UNHINGED, I DON'T
MEAN "THE VIEW," THERE'S NOTHING
TINY ABOUT THEMF THEY WOULD
RATHER POLICE LANGUAGE THAN
ACTUALLY DANGEROUS NUTS ON THE
STREETS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS DEFUND THE
LANGUAGE POLICE.
TO THEM, EVERYTHING IS A THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY, EXCEPT CRIMINALS.
FREE SPEECH, A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
VOTER ID, THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
VOTER BURNING DOWN A POLICE
STATION, PRICELESS.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT YOU OR ME.
WE DIDN'T RAISE THIS A-HOLE OR
FRY HIS BRAIN WITH DRUGS OR
ENCOURAGE HIM TO OVERSTAY HIS
VISA, THAT'S YOUR PLAN, MR.
NEWSOM.
HE WAS AN ILLEGAL ALIEN,
MENTALLY ILL, HOMELESS PERSON.
WHAT'S BEEN THE PARTY DEALING
WITH ALL THREE?
DEMOCRATS.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN CANADA'S
PROBLEM LIKE POLAR BEARS AND
JUSTIN BIEBER.
SORRY, IT'S YOU ON THE HOOK, THE
DEMOCRATS, YOU'RE FULL OF
COUNTLESS VICTIMS.
BUT IT DIDN'T MATTER, YOU
WEREN'T RELATED TO THEM.
NO ONE HAS BEEN ABLE TO TURN ONE
OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL STATES IN
THE COUNTRY TO A DANGEROUS
DISTAUPE YEAH THAT PEOPLE ARE
FLEEING FROM LIKE RATS FROM THE
TITANIC LIKE YOU.
WHY DON'T YOU LOOK IN THE MIRROR
COMBING YOUR MOP FOR THE 25th
TIME OF THE DAY AND ASK
YOURSELF, MAYBE IS SOME OF THIS
MY FAULT?
SO THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA
ARE EXPLOITING THE PELOSI ATTACK
TO DISTRACT FROM THEIR FAILURE
IN DEALING WITH CRIME.
PAUL PELOSI IS NOT THE FIRST TO
BE ATTACKED BY A CRAZY PERSON BY
A BLUNT OBJECT THIS YEAR.
KIM GLASS WAS HIT BY A METAL
PIPE BY A NUT IN L.A.
AND JESSE WATTERS HASN'T
CRITICIZED VOLLEYBALL SINCE THEY
SWITCHED TO SNUGGER UNIFORMS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A MAD MAN
PROBLEM.
AND IF YOU POINT IT OUT, THEY'LL
TELL YOU, NO, IT'S YOU.
IT'S NOT THEIR AMBIVALENCE
TOWARDS CRIME OR MENTAL ILLNESS,
IT'S JANUARY 6, TRUMPERS, MAGA
COUNTRY, RONALD REAGAN,
ELEPHANTS, STRAIGHT WHITE MEN,
WHATEVER.
WHAT SAY YOU, WHOOPY.
>> FOX NEWS, SOME OF THIS IS ON
YOUR HANDS.
SO SOME OF THIS IS ON YOUR
HANDS.
I'M CALLING YOU ALL OUT.
STOP WITH THE THAT SIDE IS NOT
GOOD.
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT IT -- THIS
IS WHAT IT PUT OUT THERE.
IT TELLS PEOPLE THAT YOU THINK
IT'S OKAY TO DO THIS.
STOP DOING IT.
>> Greg: WELL, THAT WAS EASY FOR
YOU TO SAY.
SORRY, WHOOPIE.
IF NANCY OR GAVIN HAD LISTENED
TO OUR CHANNEL, MAYBE THAT NUT
WOULD HAVE BEEN
INSTITUTIONALIZED.
MAYBE THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
POLICE, MORE SECURITY.
THAT'S ALL WE TALK ABOUT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Greg: THAT'S OUR WHEEL HOUSE.
BUT, NO, IT'S LIKE THEY ONLY
WATCH CNN AND MSNBC OR "THE
VIEW" WITH WHERE YOU DISPENSE
BAD ADVICE LIKE ITS FENTANYL.
NOW THEY CAN'T BE HONEST ABOUT
CRIME WHEN ONE OF THEIR OWN GETS
HIT WITH A HAMMER.
WHEN THEY PLAY WHACK-A-MOLE WITH
ANY SPEECH THEY DON'T LIKE,
ANYTHING LOOKS LIKE A NAIL.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
GROWING UP ON A CATTLE FARM
PREPARED HIM FOR ALL OF THE
MANURE IN DC, AUTHOR OF THE
GREAT NEW BOOK, "ONLY THE
STRONG," SENATOR TOM COTTON.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SHE'LL MAKE YOUR HEART GO SOFT
AS SHE TALKS YOUR EAR OFF.
OUTNUMBERS CO-HOST EMILY
CAMPAGNO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Greg: CROWDS AT HIS SHOWS ARE
LINING UP TO PULL THE FIRE
ALARM.
WRITER AND COMEDIAN JOE DeVITO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Greg: AND FINALLY, SHE'S
HANGING ON BY A THREAD, WHICH IS
FUN, BECAUSE SHE WEIGHS LIKE 90
POUNDS, FOX'S CONTRIBUTOR, KAT
TRIP.
SENATOR, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
GREAT NEW BOOK.
I JUST STARTED IT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT'S CALLED "ONLY THE STRONG"
BASED ON ME, RIGHT?
>> ONLY ABOUT YOU, GREG.
>> Greg: I WOULD HOPE SO.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR THIS KIND OF
RHETORIC FROM OTHER PEOPLE
BLAMING US, IT'S LIKE THE RIOTS
NEVER HAPPENED?
IT'S LIKE THE LOOTING NEVER
HAPPENED?
IT'S LIKE BURN IT ALL DOWN WAS
NEVER SAID?
IT'S SOMEHOW CONSERVATIVES ARE
RUNNING AROUND EGGING ON MOBS OF
VIOLENCE.
THEY FORGET ABOUT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
THEY FORGET ABOUT ALL OF THAT
STUFF.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> YEAH, AND REMEMBER GAVIN
NEWSOM BEFORE HE WAS THE FAILED
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA WAS THE
FAILED MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO.
HE'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROBLEMS IN SAN FRANCISCO
SPECIFICALLY.
SAN FRANCISCO STYLES ITSELF AS A
SANCTUARY CITY WHERE THEY
WELCOME ILLEGAL ALIENS LIKE THIS
DER RANGED LUNATIC THAT ATTACKED
PAUL PRO SI.
SAN FRANCISCO HAD ONE OF THE
FIRST SOROS PROSECUTORS UNTIL
THEY KICKED HIM OUT.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A CRIME WAVE
DEVASTATE THIS AMERICAN CITY.
AND FOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO BLAME IT
ON REPUBLICANS WHO POINT OUT
THAT NANCY PELOSI HAS DONE
THINGS LIKE PASS OBAMA CARE OR
CAUSE INFLATION WITH $5 TRILLION
WE DON'T HAVE IS THE HEIGHT OF
HYPOCRISY.
BUT NOT CRACKING DOWN ON CRIME,
NOT THROWING THE BOOKS AT THEM,
BY WELCOMING ILLEGAL ALIENS, YOU
HAVE THIS CRIME ON THE STREETS.
IT'S NOT JUST PAUL PELOSI, IT'S
ALL OF THE NORMAL CALIFORNIANS
WHO AREN'T MARRIED TO THE
SPEAKER WHO SUFFER THE MOST.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
EXACTLY.
EMILY, IS THIS REALLY JUST ABOUT
HAIRLINE?
>> UM --
>> Greg: GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS LIKE
LOOKING AT JESSE'S HAIR.
SOME WEIRD BIZARRE SUBLIMINAL
COMPETITION?
>> PROBABLY, THAT'S HOW HE ALSO
SETS HIS TARGETS ON GOVERNOR
DESANTIS TOO, RIGHT?
THE GUYS COMPETING FOR HIM IN
THE LOOKS DEPARTMENT, SO SAY
SOME PEOPLE.
I USED TO LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO,
SENATOR, UNDER THEN MAYOR
NEWSOM'S REIGN.
HE TALKS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
SEWAGE HE SAYS THAT IS AMPLIFIED
ON-LINE THAT'S SPEWED OUT BY
THESE NETWORKS.
I HAD TO ENDURE HIS SEWAGE FROM
THE BEGINNING.
HIS POLICIES ARE THE SEWAGE.
THEY HAVE LED TO THE ACTUAL
SEWAGE ON THE STREETS OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE MY FRIENDS WHO
WHO STILL LIVE THERE HAVE TO
WADE THROUGH ON THEIR WAY TO GET
TO WORK.
IT'S CHOKING THE FISH TO THE
TUNE OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
TAXPAYERS IN THAT CITY ARE ON
THE HOOK FOR.
IT'S LITERALLY FULL OF [ BLEEP ]
OUT OF HIS MOUTH AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
SO, WHEN PEOPLE LIKE SWALWELL,
TOO, WHO REPRESENTS ACROSS THE
BAY FROM DUBLIN AND SAYS,
THERE'S NO COLLEAGUE OF MINE
THAT'S ADVOCATED FOR VIOLENCE,
THIS SHOW IS NOT LONG ENOUGH TO
RUN THROUGH THAT LITANY,
EVERYONE FROM MAXINE WATERS TO
BRET BOWMAN.
THERE'S A CIVIL WAR IF THE GOP
WINS, NANCY PELOSI TALKING ABOUT
THE SUPREME COURT.
THAT RHETORIC DOES MATTER.
BUT I SAY THE RESPONSIBILITY, I
SAY, LIES AT THE TOP.
BEFORE JUSTICE KAVANAUGH HAD A
WOULD-BE ASSASSIN ON HIS FRONT
LAWN, THERE WAS NOTHING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THERE WAS NOTHING FROM THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL AT THE VERY
TOP.
THAT SAID, I CONDEMN THIS
RHETORIC OF VIOLENCE -- NO,
EVERYONE, TONE IT DOWN.
LET'S BE CONCILIATORY.
LET ME BE THAT UNIFIER IN CHIEF
I CAMPAIGNED ON BEING.
SO ALL OF THIS SIMMERING,S OF
COURSE IT'S GOING TO BE
INCENDIARY, IT'S GOING TO LEAD
TO SOMEONE ON KAVANAUGH'S LAW
THAT THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA HAS
FORGOTTEN AND THIS GUY IN HIS
BUS, WHATEVER.
THE BOTTOM LINE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION DID NOTHING TO
CURB IT FROM THE BEGINNING SO
ALL OF THIS DIDN'T LEAD TO THAT
EXPLODED PIMPLE THAT IS THAT
GUY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, JOE, YOU ALSO
LIVE IN A BUS.
SO YOU MIGHT HAVE SOME INSIGHT?
INSIGHT INTO THE PSYCHE OF THIS
UNBALANCED MAN?
DID YOU KNOW HIM AT ALL?
DID YOU -- DID PEOPLE IN BUSES?
DO THEY TALK TO EACH OTHER?
>> YOU DO ZEALOT OF RIGHT WING
RADICALS ON BUSES WITH RAINBOW
FLAGS AND BE BLM SIGNS AS A
CALLING CARD.
>> Greg: THIS GUY IS ALL OVER
THE MAP.
IT'S A POLITICAL ATTACK.
HE SAID IT WAS A POLITICAL
ATTACK.
>> IT COULD HAVE BEEN ELIZABETH
WARREN HITTING HIM IN THE HEAD
WITH A TOMAHAWK.
THAT'S THE ONLY TIME THEY WOULD
HAVE SAID SHE'S WHITE.
THEY WOULD HAVE BLAMED IT ON
HIMF THEY WERE GOING THERE FOR A
ROUTINE WELLNESS CHECK AND THEY
GET THERE AND NOW IT'S TWO GUYS
FIGHTING OVER A HAMMER IN THEIR
UNDERWEAR, WHICH, IN SAN
FRANCISCO, IS CONSIDERED A
ROUTINE WELLNESS CHECK, LET'S BE
HONEST.
IT'S ABSURD THEY SAY IT'S A
RESULT OF POLICIES, AS YOU
MENTIONED, THE POLICIES THEY'RE
AGAINST WOULD HAVE PREVENTED
THIS FROM HAPPENING.
>> Greg: AMEN.
>> THE SEWAGE AS A METAPHOR WHEN
IT'S LITERAL SEWAGE IN THE
STREETS.
HE SAID IT CREATES AN
ENVIRONMENT.
THE ENVIRONMENT YOU CREATED IS
CAMPS WITH DRUG ADDICTS AND
UNTREATED MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE.
PEOPLE COMING FROM CANADA WHO
SHOULDN'T BE HERE.
WE HAVE TO BUILD THAT WALL.
WE CAN'T HAVE THESE CANADIANS
COMING DOWN HERE.
>> Greg: PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT THE
CANADIAN WALL.
>> YOU GIVE AN INCH AND THEY
WILL TAKE 1.6 KILOMETERS.
>> Greg: THAT'S VERY FUNNY.
YOU HAVE TO SAY BUILD THAT WALL,
EH?
ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW, KAT, WHAT
DO YOU ACCEPT THE MEDIA'S CLAIM
IS IT'S ABOUT RHETORIC.
WHAT'S THE SOLUTION THEN?
THAT'S THE BEAUTY.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO SOLVE IT.
EXCEPT TO SAY, THAT'S YOUR
FAULT.
>> YEAH, HE SAID FOX NEWS, WHICH
I DON'T TAKE -- I DO TAKE
PERSONALLY.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, IT'S NOT JESSE
WATTERS' FAULT THAT HE DID THIS.
BUT -- GAVIN NEWSOM SAID HE WAS
SO FAMOUS THAT EVEN HIS
BUS-DWELLING LUNATIC KNOWS NOT
ONLY WHO HE IS BUT WHAT
DISCUSSES ON HIS SHOW.
THAT'S A HUGE COMPLIMENT IN A
WAY.
LIKE, THERE'S HOUSE HOLD NAME,
AND THEN THERE'S DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE A HOUSE HOLD NAME.
THAT'S LIKE FAME-FAME, BABY.
>> Greg: I TOTALLY DISAGREE.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT GUY KNEW WHO
JESSE WAS.
>> I KNOW, BUT GAVIN NEWSOM
THINKS JESSE IS THAT FAMOUS.
I WOULD SAY THANK YOU, GAVIN,
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I AM A STAR.
>> HE'S A BUS-HOLD NAME.
>> Greg: HE'S A BUS-HOLD NAME.
>> NO WAY HE KNEW WHO JESSE
WATTERS IS.
>> Greg: AMAZING.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO BE A BUS-HOLD
NAME.
>> NOT EVEN ONE TH